[footsteps]
Hey, how's it going?
Hey!
[footsteps walking back]
Wait, what is
Yale Club Jump Rope?
Hold on you're telling me you've
never heard of Club Jump Rope!?
No?
Yeah, fair enough.
We're pretty new.
We’re Yale’s newest club sport.
We do performances, competitions
It's a good workout,
but mostly
it’s just a fun group of people
to hang out with.
You know, this sounds like
something I'd be interested in.
Oh, awesome!
[upbeat saxophone music]
I'll warn you though,
I haven't done this
since elementary school.
♪
That's totally fine,
we'll teach you everything!
But...
Don’t worry about it,
just follow along!
[group claps]
clap clap
♪ Let’s celebrate ♪
♪ Dance to the beat ♪
♪ Forget the woes ♪
♪ And stomp the feet now ♪
♪ The fun and games ♪
♪ And memories ♪
♪ I’d love to share ♪
♪ With my family ♪
♪ And everything is better ♪
♪ When we get together ♪
♪ Everything is better ♪
♪ When we are side by side...
[record scratch]
[silence]
[laughing and swooning
over Handsome Dan]
look at him, he’s so cute!
[music starts again]
♪ Hey-yay-ay ♪
♪ Side by side ♪
♪ When we are side by side ♪
♪
♪ Side by side ♪
♪ Side by side ♪♪
♪♪
[footsteps]
Hey, what’s
Yale Club Jump Rope?
You’ve never heard
of Yale Club Jump Rope!?
♪